today we're going to start talking about
what's under
the demand curve so basically what we
did last time and what you did in
section Friday is talk about sort of the
workhorse model of economics which is
applying demand model and we always
start the class with that because that's
the D model in the course but I think is
any good sort of scientists and
inquisitive minds you're probably
immediately asking well where do these
supplying demand curves come from
they're not just come out of thin air
how how do we think about them where do
they come from and that's what we'll
spend the base of the first half of the
course going through and so we're gonna
start today with the demand curve and
the demand curve is gonna come from how
consumers make choices okay and that
will help us derive the demand curve
then we'll turn next to supply curve
which would come from how firms make
production decisions but let's start
with the demand curve and we're gonna
start by talking to you about people's
preferences and then their utility
functions okay so our model of consumer
decision-making is going to be a model
of utility maximization that's going to
be our fundamental remember of course
all about constrained maximization our
model today's can model if utility
maximization and this model is going to
have two components there's going to be
consumer preferences which is what
people want and there's gonna be a
budget constraint which is what they can
afford and we're gonna put these two
things together we're going to maximize
people's happiness or their choice or
their their happiness given their
preferences subject to the budget
constraint they face and that could be
the constrained maximization exercise
that actually through the magic of
economics is going to yield the demand
curve and its yield a very sensible
domain curve that you'll understand
intuitively now so we're gonna do is do
this in three steps step one over the
next two lectures
step one is we'll talk about preferences
how do we model people's tastes we'll do
that today
step two we'll talk about how we
translate this to utility function how
we mathematically represent people's
preferences in the utility function
we'll do that today as well and then
next time
we'll talk about the budget constraints
that people face so today we're going to
talk about the maxim and next time we'll
talk about the budget constraint that
means today's lecture is quite fun
today's lectures about unconstrained
choice we're not going to worry all
about what you can afford what anything
costs
well worry about what things cost and a
quarter of what you can afford
okay today's the lecture where you won
the lottery okay you won the lottery
money is no object how do you think
about what you want okay
next time we'll say well you didn't win
the lottery in fact is we run later in
the semester no when's the lottery
that's an incredibly bad deal but basic
time will impose the budget constraints
but for today we're just going to ignore
that and talk about what do you want
okay
and to start this we're gonna start with
the series of preference assumptions a
series remember as I talked about last
time models rely on simplifying
assumptions otherwise we could never
write down a model it'll go on forever
okay and the key question is are those
simplifying assumptions sensible do they
do violence to reality in a way which
makes you not believe the model or are
they roughly consistent with reality in
a way that allows you to go on with the
model okay and we're gonna post three
preference assumptions which I hope will
not violate your sense of reasonableness
the first is completeness what I mean by
that is you have preferences over any
set of goods you might choose from you
might be indifferent you might say like
a as much as B but you can't say I don't
care or I don't know exact err that's a
difference you can't say I don't know
you can't literally say I don't know how
I feel about this um you might say
you're indifferent to things but you
won't say I don't know how I feel about
something that's completely okay the
second is the assumption we've all
become familiar with since kindergarten
math which is transitivity if you prefer
a to B and B to C you prefer A to C okay
that's that's kind of I'm sure that's
pretty clear you've done this a lot in
other classes so these two are sort of
standard assumption you might make any
math class the third assumption is the
one where the economics comes in which
is the assumption of non-satiation or
the assumption of more is better in this
class we will assume more is always
better than less okay
we'll assume more is better than less
now to be clear we're not going to say
that the next unit makes you equally
happy as the last unit in fact I'll talk
about that in a few minutes
well in fact assume it makes you less
happy but we will say you always want
more that face with a chance of more or
less you'll always be happier with more
okay and that's the non-satiation
assumption okay and I'll talk about that
some during a lecture but that's sort of
what's going to give our models their
power that's a sort of New Economics
assumption that's going to give beyond
our typical math assumptions this can
you give our models their power okay so
that's our assumptions so armed with
those
I want to start with the graphical
representation of preferences when
graphically represent people's
preferences and I'll do so through
something we call indifference curves
indifference curves okay
these are based indifference curves are
basically preference maps especially
difference curves are graphical Maps a
preferences okay so for example suppose
your parents gave you some money to
begin a semester and you spend that
money on two things your parents are
rich to give you tons of money spend
that money on two things buying pizza or
C or um or eating cookies okay
so consider your considered preferences
between pizza and cookies that's your
two things you can do once again there's
constrain model obviously in life we can
do a million things with your money but
it turns out if we consider the contrast
we can do a tutor for things with your
money you get a rich set of intuition
that you can apply to a month much more
multi-dimensional decision case so let's
start with a two dimensional decision
case you've got your money either gonna
have pizza or gonna have cookies okay
now consider three choices
okay choice a is two pizzas and one
cookie choice B is one Pizza one pizza
and two cookies and choice C is two
pizzas two cookies okay that's the three
packages I want to compare and I'm going
to assume and I'll mathematically
rationalize in a few minutes but for now
I'm going to assume you are indifferent
between these two packages I'm going to
assume you're equally happy with two
slices of pizza and one cookie or two
cookies and one slice of pizza okay I'm
gonna assume that but I'm also gonna
assume you prefer option C to both of
these in fact I'm not I'm gonna assume
that because that is what more is better
gives you okay so your different view
nice this indifference doesn't come from
any property road I'll buy that's an
assumption that's just a just for this
case I'm assuming that this comes to the
third prop
I rode up there you prefer package chic
as more is always better than less okay
so now let's graph your preferences and
we do so in Figure two one OK in the
handout
okay so here's your indifference curve
so we've graphed on the x-axis your
number of number of cookies on the
y-axis slices of pizza okay now you have
we've graphed the three choices I laid
here choice a which is two slices of
pizza and one cookie choice B which is
two cookies in one slice of pizza and
choice C which is two of both and I've
drawn on this graph here indifference
curves the way indifference curves looks
is there's one indifference curve
between a and B because those are the
points among which you're indifferent so
when a difference curve represents is
all combinations of consumption among
which you are indifferent so why we call
it a difference curve so a difference
curve which will be sort of with the big
warhorses of this course a difference
curve represents all combinations along
which you are indifferent you are
indifferent between a and B therefore
they lie on the same curve okay so
that's sort of our preference map our
indifference curves and these
indifference curves are gonna have four
properties four properties that you have
two that follow naturally from this
that's really three and a half the third
and fourth are really pretty much the
same but I like to write the minus four
for properties that follow from the from
these underlying assumptions property
one is consumers prefer higher
indifference curves consumers prefer
higher indifference curves okay and that
just fall for more is better that is an
indifference curve that's higher goes to
their package that has at least as much
of one thing and more of the other thing
therefore you prefer it okay so as a
difference curve shift out people are
happier okay so in that higher
indifference curve Point C you are
happier than points a and B because more
is better okay
the second is that indifference curves
never cross indifference curves never
cross okay actually that's I'm gonna
that's third actually I want to come to
that in order second third is the
difference occurs whoever's second is
indifference curves are downward sloping
seconds and difference curves are
downward sloping
okay indifference curves are downward
sloping let's talk about that first okay
that simply comes from the principle of
non-satiation so look at figure two -
here's an upward sloping indifference
curve okay why does that violate the
principle non-satiation why does that
violate that yeah they're yours less how
do you have work like or
yeah exactly so basically you're
indifferent on this curve you're
indifferent me one of each and two of
each you can't be indifferent two of
each has got to be better than one of
each so an upward sloping and DIF curve
would violate non-satiation so that's
the second property of indifference
curve the third property may discover
the difference curves never cross okay
we could see that in Figure two three
okay someone else tell me why this
violates the properties I wrote up their
indifference curves crossing yeah what's
that
cuz the B and C P is strictly better
that's right but but they're they're
also but they're also both on the same
curve is a so you're saying they're both
you're indifferent with a for both B and
C but you can't be because B is strictly
better than C so violates transitivity
okay so the problem with crossing
indifference curves they violate
transitivity and then finally the fourth
is sort of a cute extra assumption but I
think it's important to clarify which is
that there is only one indifference
curve through every possible consumption
bundle only one I see through every
bundle okay
you can't have two indifference curves
going through the same bundle okay and
that's because of completeness if you
have two and difference Coast wants the
same bundle you wouldn't know how you
felt okay so they can only be one going
through every bundle cuz you know how
you feel
you may feel indifferent but you know
how you feel you can't say I don't know
okay so that's sort of a extra
assumption sort of completes the link to
the properties okay so that's basically
how indifference curves work now I find
when I took this course before you were
God maybe before your parents were born
I don't know certainly before you guys
were born okay when I took this course I
found this course full of a lot of light
bulb moments that is stuff will just
sort of these and then boom an example
really make it work for me and the
example that made indifference curves
work to me was actually during my first
UROP when my Europe was with a grad
student and that grad student had to
decide where he was can accept the job
he'd a series of job obviously I decide
and basically said here's the way I'm
thinking about it I'm indifferent I
haven't I have indifference map but I
care about two things I care about
school location and I care about
Economics Department quality okay I care
about the quality of my colleagues and
the research that's done there in the
location and basically his he had two
offers one was from Princeton which he
put up here no offense to New Jerseyans
but Princeton as a young single person
sucks
okay fine when you're married to have
kids but deadlies young single person
and the other so that's Princeton down
here was Santa Cruz
okay awesome candidates the most
beautiful University in America okay but
not as good an economics department and
he decided he was roughly and different
between the two but he had a third offer
from the IMF which is the research
institution in DC which has he had a lot
of good colleagues NDC's way better than
Princeton New Jersey even it's not as
good to see him to Cruz so he decided he
would take the offer at the IMF okay
even though the IMF had worse colleagues
in Princeton and worse location of Santa
Cruz it was still better in combination
the two of them given his preferences
and that's how he used in different
skirts he'll make his decision okay so
that's sort of an example of of applying
and once again no offense to the New
Jerseyans in the room of which I am one
but believe me you'd rather be in Santa
Cruz okay so now let's go from
preferences to utility functions
okay so now we're gonna move from
preferences which we represent
graphically to utility functions which
we're gonna represent mathematically
remember I want you understand
everything in this course at three
levels graphically mathematically and
most importantly of all intuitively okay
so graphic is indifference curves now
we'll come to the mathematical
representation which utility function
okay and the idea is that every
individual all of you in this room have
a stable well behaved underlying
mathematical representation of your
preferences which we call utility
function okay now once again that's to
be very complicated your preference over
lots of different things we're gonna
make things simple by writing out
two-dimensional representation for now
of your indifference curve we're gonna
say how do we a mathematically represent
your feelings about Pizza versus cookies
okay imagine that's all you care about
in the world is pizza and cookies how do
we a mathematically represent that so
for example we could write down that
your utility function is equal to the
square root of the number of slice of
pizza
times the number of cookies we could
write that down I'm not saying that's
right I'm not saying it works for anyone
in this room or even everyone this room
but that is a possible way to represent
utility okay what this would say this is
convenient we will use we'll end up
using square roots formal law for
utility functions a lot of convenient
mathematical properties and it happens
to jibe with our example right because
in this example you're different between
two pizzas and one cookie or one pizza
to cookie that both square root of two
and you prefer two beats and two cookies
that's two okay so this gives you a high
utility for two pits and two cookies
okay then one pizza then one Pete's and
two cookie or two pizza and one cookie
so now the question is what does this
mean
what is utility okay well utility
doesn't actually mean anything
there's not really a thing out there
called noodles okay in other words
utility is not a cardinal concept it is
only an ordinal concept
you cannot say your utility you are you
cannot literally say
my utilities X % higher than your
utility but you can rank them so we're
gonna assume that utility can be ranked
to allow you to rank choices even if
generally we might slip some and sort of
pretend utilities Cardinal for some cute
examples but by and large we're gonna
think of utility as purely ordinal it's
just a way to rank your choices it's
just when you have a set of choices out
there were many dimensions a if your
choice in life was always over one
dimension and more was better it would
always be easier to rank it right you'd
never have a problem once your choice
over more than one dimension now if you
want to rank them you need some way to
combine them that's what this function
does it allows you essentially to weight
the different elements of your
consumption bundle so you can rank them
when it comes time to choose okay now
this is obviously incredibly simple but
it turns out to be amazingly powerful in
explaining real world behavior okay and
so I want to do today's work with the
underlying mathematics of utility and
then we'll come back we'll see in the
next few lectures how it could actually
be used to explain decisions so a key
concept we're gonna talk about in this
class is marginal utility margit hill is
just the derivative of the utility
function with respect to one of the
elements so there marg utility for
cookies of cookies is utility of the
next cookie given how many cookies
you've had this class can be very
focused on marginal decision making in
economics it's all about how you think
about the next unit turns out that makes
life a ton easier turns out it's way
easier to say do you want the next
cookie then they say how many cookies do
you want because if you want the next we
that's sort of a very isolated decision
you say ok I've had this many cookies do
I want the next cookie whereas before
you start eating today how many cookies
do you want that's sort of a harder more
global decision so we're gonna focus on
this stepwise decision making process of
do you want the next unit
the next cook your the next slice of
pizza ok and the key feature of utility
functions we'll work with throughout the
semester is that they will feature
diminishing
diminishing marginal utility Mars
utility will fall as you have more of a
good the more of a good you've had the
less happiness you'll derive from the
next unit okay now we can see that
graphically in Figure two for figure two
for graphs on the x-axis the number of
cookies holding constant pizza so let's
say you're having two pizza slices and
you want to say what's my benefit from
the next cookie and I'm on the Left axis
violating what I just said like 15
seconds ago we graph utility now once
again the util numbers don't mean
anything it's just to give you an
ordinal sense what you see here is that
if you have one cookie your utility is
1.4 square root of two times one if you
have two cookies utility goes up to
square root of four which is two you are
happy with two cookies but you are less
happy from the second cookie than the
first cookie okay and you could see that
in Figure if you flip back and forth 3
to 4 and 2/5 you can see that okay the
first cookie going from zero to one
cookie gave you one so in this case
we're not graphing the margin utility so
figure 2 4 is the level of utility which
is not really something you can measure
in fact figure 2 5 is something you can
measure which is margin utility what's
your happiness we'll talk about
measuring this from the next cookie you
see the first cookie gives you a utility
and a utility increment of 1.4 okay you
go for utility of zero two utility one
point for the next cookie gives utility
in current of 0.59 ok you go from
utility of one point four one two
utility of to the next cookie gives
utility increment of 0.45 the square
root of 3 so now we flip back to the
previous page we're going from the
square root of 4 so we're going from the
square root of 4 I'm sorry to the square
root of 6 square root of 6 is only 0.45
more than the square root of 4 and so on
so each additional cookie makes you less
and less happy it makes you happier it
has to because more is better but
makes you less and less happy okay and
this makes sense just think about any
decision in life starting with nothing
of something and having the first one
slice of pizza a cookie deciding on
which movie to go to the first movie the
one you want to see the most okay it's
gonna make you happier then you want to
see the one you want to see not quite as
much the first cookie when you're hungry
will make you happier than the second
cookie the first slice of pizza make
happen now you may be close to
indifferent that second slice of pee she
makes you almost as happy as the first
but the first will make you happier okay
if you think about that's really sort of
that first step you were hungry in that
first one makes you feel happier now but
you got to remember you always want more
cookies now you might say wait a second
this is stupid okay once I've had 10
cookies I'm gonna barf the 11th cookie
you can actually make me worse off
because I don't like barfing but in
economics we have to remember you don't
have to eat the 11th cookie you could
give it away so if I save you want the
11th cookie you can save it for later
you could give it to a friend so you
always want it in the worst case you
throw it out it can't make you're worse
off it could only make you better off
and that's what we're sort of more is
better assumption comes from obviously
in the limit you know if you get a
million cookies they're garbage game
gets full you have no friends to give
them to I understand the limit these
things fall apart okay but that's a
basic idea of Moore's better than the
basic idea of diminishing marginal
utility
okay any questions about that yeah
utility function can never be negative
because we get well utility once again
utility is not an ordinal concept you
can set up utility functions such that
the numbers negative you can set that up
okay
the margin utility is always positive
you always get some benefit from the
next unit utility once again the
measurements are relevant so you can be
negative to get set it up yeah I could
write my utility function like this you
know something like that so it could be
negative that's just a sort of scaling
factor but marginal utility is always
positive
you're always happier or it's not it's
not negative you're always happy or at
least indifferent to get in the next
unit yeah
uh I'm sorry you look think you're to
five know the marginal because he can go
down each fraction of a cookie the Marge
utility marshal is always diminishing
well it's really hard to do it from zero
that's really tricky it's sort of much
easy to start from one
so corner solutions we'll talk a lot of
corner solutions as class they get ugly
think of it starting from one starving
that first cookie every fraction of a
cookie makes you happier but less and
less happy with each fraction good
question alright good questions alright
so now let's let's talk about let's slip
back from the math to the graphics and
talk about where indifference curves
come from I just drew them out but in
fact indifference curves are the
graphical representation of what comes
out of utility function okay and indeed
the slope of the indifference curve
we're gonna call the marginal rate of
substitution the rate essentially at
which you're willing to substitute one
good for the other larae willing to
substitute cookies for pizza is your
marginal rate of substitution and we'll
define that as the slope of the
indifference curve Delta P over Delta C
that is your marginal rate of
substitution little indifference curve
tells you the rate should will in a
substitute you just follow along and say
look I'm willing to give up so in other
words if you look at figure two six you
say look I'm indifferent between point A
and point B one cut one slice of pizza
I'm sorry one cookie and four slices of
pizza is the same to me as two cookies
two slices to B so why is it the same
because they both give me utility square
root of four right so given this
mathematical I'm not saying you are I'm
saying give me this mathematical
representation okay you aren't different
between point a and point B so what that
says and what's the slope with the
indifference curve what's the arc slope
between point a and point B the slope is
negative two so your marginal rate of
substitution is negative two
you aren't different okay you're in
different between 1/4 and 2 2 therefore
you're willing to substitute or give
away two slices of pizza to get one
cookie Delta P Delta C is is negative 2
okay
now it turns out you can define the
margin rate of substitution over any
segment of a difference curve and what's
interesting is it changes it diminishes
look what happens when we move from two
pizzas and two cookies to from point B
to Point C now the margeurite sub
solution only negative 1/2
now I'm only willing to give up one
slice of pizza to get two cookies what's
happening first I was willing give up to
slice of pizza get one cookie now only
wouldn't give up willing to give up one
slice apiece so to get two cookies
what's happening yeah because of exactly
diminishing margin Atilla T has caused
the margin rate of substitution itself
to itself to diminish for those who are
really kind of better at math than I am
it turns out technically mathematically
large utilities and always diminishing
you can drop cases mrs is always
diminishing so you can think of margin
is always diminishing it's fine for this
class we get the higher-level math and
economics you'll see Marge utility
doesn't have to diminish mrs has to
diminish okay
mrs is always diminishing as you go
along the indifference curve that slope
is always falling okay so basically what
we can right now is how the mrs relates
utility function our first sort of
mind-blowing result is that the mrs is
equal to the negative of the Margy
utility of cookies over the marge
utility of pizza that's our first key
definition its equal to the negative of
the margit Ilia the good on the x-axis
over the marge utility good although on
the y-axis okay essentially the madre
substitution tells you how your relative
marginal utilities evolve as you move
down the indifference curve when you
start at Point a
you have lots of Pizza and not a lot of
cookies when you have lots of pizza your
margin utility is small here's the key
insight this is the thing which once
again it's a light bulb thing if you get
this and make your life so much easier
margin utilities are negative functions
of quantity the more you have of a thing
the less you want the next unit of it
that's why for example cookies is now in
the numerator and pizzas in the
denominator flipping from this side okay
the more you have the good the less you
want it so start at Point a you have
lots of pizza and not a lot of cookies
you don't really want more pizza you
want more cookies that means the
denominator is small the mores utility
of pizza is small you don't really want
it but the marginal if cookies is high
you don't many of them so this is a big
number now let's move to point B and
think about your DX decision well now
your margin Chile of Pizza if you're
gonna go from two to one slice of pizza
now Pizza is worth a lot more than
cookies so now it gets smaller so
essentially as you move along that
indifference curve because of this you
want because diminishing margin Atilla T
it leads this issue of a diminishing
marginal rate of substitution okay so
basically as you along indifference
curve you're more and more willing to
give up the good on the x-axis to get
the good on the y-axis as you move from
the upper left to the lower right on
that indifference map figure two six
you're well you're more willing to give
up the good on the on the x-axis to get
the good on the y-axis and what this
implies is that indifference curves are
con indifference curves are convex to
the origin indifference curves are
convex to the origin it's very important
okay that let's see that they are they
are not concave theory the convex are
straight let's say they're net they're
not concave to the origin okay to be
technical difference curves can be
linear we'll come to that
but they can't be concave the origin why
well let's look at the next figure the
last figure figure 2:7 what would happen
if indifference curves were concave to
the origin then that would say moving
from one pizza so now I've drawn a
concave indifference curve and with this
is curved if it's curved move from point
A to point B leaves you indifference so
you're happy to give up one slice of
pizza to get one cookie starting with
four slice of beats in one cookie you
are happy to give up one slice of pizza
to get one cookie now starting from two
and three you're now willing to give up
two slices of pizza to get one cookie
what does that violate why is that not
make sense yeah yeah glad to vision
margin utility here you were you were
you were only you were happy to have one
slice speeds to get one cookie now I
really have to slice to pieces to get
won't cook even though you have less
pizza and more cookies that can't be
right as you have less pizza more
cookies cookies pizzas should become
more valuable not less valuable and
cookies should become less valuable not
more valuable so a concave to the origin
indifference curve would violate the
principle diminishing marginal and
diminishing marginal rate of
substitution okay
yeah okay
that's very interesting so in some sense
what that is saying is that your utility
function is really over sets you're
saying utility functions and over
trading cards it's over sets so
basically that's what sort of you know
what's sort of a bit you know our models
are flexible one way say they're loose
another way say they're flexible so one
but one of the challenges you'll face on
this course
is thinking about what is decision set
over which I'm writing my utility
function you're saying it's that's not
trading cards so that's why it happens
ok other questions good question yeah in
the back what about like addictive
things were like the more you have it
the more you want to buy yeah that's
that's a really religion question I
spend a lot of my research life actually
I do a lot of read a lot of research for
a number of years on thinking about how
you properly model just addictive
decisions like smoking and making
decisions like smoking essentially it
really is that your utility function
itself shifts as you get more addictive
it's not that your margin utility the
next cigarettes still worth less than
the first cigarette it's just that as
you get more addicted that first
cigarette gets worth more and more to
you so when you wake up in the morning
feeling crappy that first cigarette
still does more for you than the second
cigarette it's just the next thing you
wake up feeling crappy er okay so we
model addiction it's something where
essentially each day cigarettes do less
and less for you get essentially
adjusted to new you get habituated to
higher levels and this is why you know I
do a lot of work you know this is why
unfortunately we saw last year the
number the highest number of deaths from
accidental overdose in US history 72,000
people died from drug overdose last year
more than ever died traffic accidents in
our nation's history okay
why because people get habituated to
certain levels and the exhibition a
certain level so people get hooked on
oxycontin they get obituaries I'm a be
switched to heroin and their [ __ ] to a
certain level and now have this thing
called fentanyl which is a synthetic
opioid brought over from China which is
incredibly powerful and dealers are
mixing the fentanyl in with the heroin
and the people shoot up not realizing
that they're habituated level not
realizing they have this dangerous
substances and they overdose and die and
that's because they've gotten habituated
to high level
they don't realize that getting a
different product so it's not about not
diminishing marginal tea it's about
different underlying different products
all right
other questions sorry for that
depressing note but it's important to be
thinking about that's why once again
we're the dismal science we have to
think about these things okay now let's
come to a great example that I hope
you've wondered about and maybe you've
already figured out in your life
but I hope you've at least stopped and
wondered about which is the prices of
different sizes of goods in a
convenience store say okay take
Starbucks you can get at all iced coffee
for 225 or the next size whatever the
hell they call it bigger okay you can
get 470 more cents so 225 and you can
double it for seventy more cents or take
McDonald's a small drink is a dollar
twenty two and the local McDonald's but
for 50 more cents you can double the
size okay what's going on here it why
did it give you twice as much liquid or
if you go for ice cream it's the same
thing
why do you view twice as much for much
less than twice as much money what's
going on yeah
exactly that's a great way to explain it
the point is it's all about diminishing
margin utility okay when you come in to
McDonald's on a hot day you are
desperate for that soda but you're not
as desperate to have twice as much soda
you'd like it
you're probably want to pay more for it
but you don't like it nearly as much as
that first Minnesota so those prices
simply reflects the market's reaction to
understanding diminishing marginal
utility now we even talked about the
supply side of the market yet I'm not
getting top providers make decisions
that's a much deeper issue I'm just
saying that this is diminishing marginal
in action how it works in the market and
that's why you see this okay so
basically um what you see is that that
first bite of ice cream for example is
worth more and that's why the ice cream
is twice as big doesn't cost twice as
much now so basically what this means is
if you think about our semantic demand
and supply model on a hot day or any day
the demands for the first 16 ounces is
higher than the demand for the second 16
ounces but the cost of perusing 16
ounces is the same so let's think about
this it's always risky when I try to
draw a graph in the board but let's bear
with me okay so let's say that there's a
simple supply and demand model you have
this you have this supply function for
soda and let's assume it's roughly flat
okay let's assume sort of the cost of
firm procedure you know within some
range the firm basically every
incremental 16 ounces cost of them the
same so that's sort of their supply
curve okay and then you have some demand
curve okay you have some demand curve
which is downward sloping okay and they
set some price and this is the demand
for 16 ounces now yeah what's the demand
for the next 16 ounces okay yeah isn't
gonna work we have to have an upward
sloping supply curve sorry about that we
have a slightly upward sloping supply
curve okay now we have the demand for
the next so so here's your here's your
price here's
dollar 22 okay now you say well what's
my demand when I sell 32 ounces well it
turns out demand as it shift out twice
as much it just shifts out a little bit
more so you can only charge a dollar 72
for the next 16 ounces probably if you
want to go to the big if you can go to
the 7-eleven where you can get sizes up
to you know as big as your house okay
they keep these curves keep getting
closer and closer to each other so those
price increments get smaller and smaller
and that's why you get the monster you
know ginormous gulp at 7-eleven is
really just not that indict not that
different from the price of getting the
small little mini size okay because the
diminishing margin utility all right and
so that's how the market that's
essentially how we can take this
abstract concept this sort of crazy math
and turn into literally what you see in
the store you walk into okay questions
about that yeah
awesome awesome question and every
single thing it was going to be your
first granola right so I
great great question yeah well I mean
the risk of my going to this model is
you know once we once we get nonlinear
we do things in this class we have to
start talking about supply factors I
want to talk to but there's two answers
one is packaging efficiencies but the
other is if you actually go to Costco
and look at their prices for many things
they're not actually better than the
supermarket so actually the price of
buying the giant like eight thousand
bars of granola is actually not that
much more than not that much less than a
thousand time buying a eight pack at
eight granola bars it turns out it's
less but it's not nearly as much less as
these examples as sodas at McDonald's
what's exactly your point utility
diminishes less so they don't want to
charge as much less in multiple packages
so you can actually if you compare
Parrish the gap in perishable product
pricing by size it's much larger than
the gap in non-perishable pricing by
size great point yeah
so there's a without recycle your
awesome and that is why they don't let
you walk back in with the same cup and
refill it right that's exactly right
and that comes to this point it's sort
of like it's non-perishable as you get
longer apart so um but you know it's all
this really should think so at Fenway
okay you can get you get like a
regular-sized soda it's like crazy it's
like six bucks then for like eight bucks
you get a big soda then for ten bucks
you get a refillable big soda okay now
the question is can you bring that
refillable soda back to additional games
technically not but I do and and
basically they sort of understand so so
this interesting question of sort of the
perishability of things and how that's
and how that's gonna affect things going
on it's a really it's a really it's an
interesting question
other comments okay I'm going to stop
there those are great comments thanks
everyone for participating and we will
come back next time and talk about the
sad reality that we haven't won the
lottery and we have limited amounts of
money